ladies and gentlemen there is as of  today a redheaded emoji yeah it's true  it's true it's true our long national  nightmare is over  the latest emoji update finally finally  includes redheads this is a big deal for  us okay and not only that but they have  created a series of specific emojis just  for redheads to communicate with for  example there is a even wear a sunscreen  when the moon is out there's do you sell  full-body bathing suits there's it's not  true look we're weaker because of  inbreeding bears I'm not related to  Conan  there's uncool doesn't mean unlovable  there's yes my ancestor was probably  raped by a Viking bears let's drink  there's let's drink some more and  there's for various reasons I cannot  drink any more and finally my favorite  yes that is my real pubic hair  [Applause]  you